Democrats beware the GOP candidates are
laser focused on the issue that could
sink the left's chances in November
education and parental rights
Republicans hammering the woke nonsense
children are learning in schools and
pledging to stand up for the rights of
parents to know about it
let's shut down the head of the snake
the Department of Education take that 80
billion dollars put it in the hands of
parents across this country the only way
we change education in this nation is to
break the backs of the teachers unions I
would get rid of the Department of
Education I would give block grants to
schools but I'd give them on Merit based
on who's doing the most Innovative the
decline in education is one of the major
reasons why our country is in Decline we
need education in this country not
indoctrination we need transparency in
the classroom because parents should
never have to wonder what's being said
or taught to their children in the
classroom
Dana the majority of people voting uh
have children 70 percent of Americans
have children how important is the
education issue given the fact that it's
they're pretty much run by the state
schools uh but also the failing National
report card that you talk about I didn't
know that statistic that's pretty
impressive one of the things that's
interesting I don't think anybody on
that stage really had any big
differences of opinion on education but
what they have collectively is an
incredible opportunity to run on
education as part of the platform for
the Republicans going forward across all
tickets from the local races uh School
Board races all the way up through the
presidency but campaigns deal in fantasy
and governing is reality and it was one
of the things that Nikki Haley talked
about yesterday especially on abortion
rights right she said well that's fine
like you could say that you're going to
end all abortions and they'll never
happen again but
she's just being realistic about how
many votes are there in the Senate so
part of the thing is I don't know any
Republican who has run for president in
my lifetime who hasn't said they're
going to abolish the Department of
Education and if that were true then
that would have happened it's just it's
a difficult thing to do it's a great
goal maybe that can so be something that
happens I think that somebody has to
declare a National Emergency on
education when it comes to the standards
the accomplishments the achievements
those are way down the Civics education
is bad and what Nikki Haley and many of
them others mentioned the parental
rights especially on the gender issue
that is a number one thing and Randy
weingartner of the teacher teachers
union went after Governor DeSantis today
so they must think okay oh they must
think that he's a problem right and I'm
sure he welcomes it you know just more
attention Jesse for the candidates uh
believer agreed that they would
eliminate the U.S Department of
Education actually what purpose does the
Department of Education serve in this
country
I I don't know
and that's an honest answer and I've
never been honest on the show and said I
didn't know something I usually pretend
like I do and but I don't know but I do
know this I do know that it's not
getting eliminated I mean it's never
going to get eliminated Republicans have
tried to eliminate government for
decades and it just grows so but the
Democrats just keep on throwing money at
schools and expecting results and if
that were true then we'd all be
matriculating Little Einsteins and
that's not happening either the
Democrats use the education system as a
money laundering opportunity for
donations as a vote harvesting
opportunity during elections and as a
brainwashing laboratory for a new
generation and they try to trap the
students in these Laboratories and then
they don't want to talk about it
Republicans are actually talking about
academic achievement and we have never
talked about that as in this detail
before but vivec had it right the
parents have to get involved you can't
just expect to send your kid to public
school and all of a sudden he's gonna
like you know Aces lsats you have to be
engaged as a parent cook the kid eggs in
the morning read the kid books check his
homework do parent-teacher conferences
maybe run for school board something
like that because they say it's all
hands off you do it you're never going
to get a smart kid like that 54 Jessica
of uh Republican voters think that
schools teach too little on reading and
writing uh 70 percent want more on good
citizenship 50 want more on math Science
and Tech how important is it to focus on
these subjects especially given our
competition with China
it's absolutely critical I think this is
one of the issues where you have
UNIF unification amongst parents who are
concerned about this who want vast
Improvement in terms of our Public
School System more opportunity for
vouchers that's popping up with more and
more Democrats like the governor of
Pennsylvania Josh Shapiro who has close
to a 60 approval rating completely
unheard of it's one of the issues that
he cares about and we all remember how
Glenn young well but that was a vote
issue yeah
it's progress what's what's going on
that it is even part of the Democratic
National discourse is a departure from
how it has been I will say though I was
watching
um Navigator research has these dials
that they're doing throughout uh the
debate seeing you know the lot the trend
lines of people like what you're saying
and when Vivek ramaswamy and Tim Scott
talked about abolishing the Department
of Education and busting the teachers
unions they fell off a cliff with
independent voters it was like straight
down and independent voters are the key
to this election Democrats and
Republicans we don't have enough on our
own without these Independents and it is
an issue as Dana said Republicans talk
about this all the time but it is
obviously not something that is
resonating with those Independents and
if you want to win a general you got to
go through them can we can we get that
uh sound on ramaswamy bringing up the
issue of fatherlessness in the United
States
this is for you Greg part of the problem
is we also have a federal government
that pays single women more not to have
a man in the house than to have a man in
the house contributing to an epidemic of
fatherlessness and I think that goes
hand in glove with the education crisis
as well because we have to remember
education starts with the family and the
nuclear family is the greatest form of
governance known to mankind
yeah it starts up that those ideas have
been around he'd be great in that seat
yeah on that seat I'm just putting it
out there the the Indian Jesse Waters
yes there you go but you know what we
predicted that the show predicted this
that when you when you combine the covet
shutdowns and the gender fascism the
education problems the crime that it
made it so that the parents had no place
in the Democratic party we talked about
this that no one listens to their
problems because their problems are then
Twisted into some form of like bigotry
or you're for some sort of genocide new
Democrats always say oh we want a
conversation we want a conversation but
if you want a conversation at a school
board meeting they're going to call you
a domestic terrorist the Democrats have
to stop embracing evil just because the
Republicans are on the side of the good
and we talked about this border crime
family uh now you can understand why the
Democrats were pro-slavery because it
was clear the Republicans weren't so I
would say the Republicans are now the
parents party
for this reason right uh because the
other side and I mean I I mean the White
House they're embracing all sorts of
weird stuff I mean child mutilation they
won't condemn that because you know they
want to own the right the Right comes
out against it the White House has to be
for it the Dems used to say children are
their future no now it's dudes and
dresses and it's the it's the
Republicans future parents are going to
start figuring this out soon Jessica and
you will soon become a republican well
that's definitely not true and also
gender affirming care is not
generalistic affirmation yeah and that's
we're gonna remove your genitals how's
that for affirmation good job Greg I
wanna Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me
a favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interview is coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now